okay buck Sexton you know I love that I
can't be the first one media said no I
know but I can't be the first one to
notice it does sound like a gay porn
star or any ports are buck Sexton it's a
fantastic porn name you don't need to
like what's your porn name your address
and no this is it start the show this
way so what do you think of Trump's
offer to help Putin with the Siberian
wildfires after he threatened to
withhold funding for he did he offered
to help with the wildfires in Siberia he
was talking about today terrible
terrible fires but he didn't help us so
I know that there there's a big
narrative out there about how everything
that Trump does look he is personally
very familiar in friendly with him and I
think that Kim jong-un stuff is is weird
just I I couldn't defend some of things
he says about Kim Jong good but on the
policy lecture on a policy level it
speaks for itself
I mean he's opposing Maduro in Venezuela
he opposes Iran which is most important
Russian allies these are not things that
Russia would wanted to do we blew up 200
Russian mercenaries in Syria folks
people just skip past that like it was
no big deal that was in the Trump
administration there are sanctions still
against Russia there's plenty of stuff
on a policy level to show and he's not
in their pocket we just pulled out of a
into a nuclear treaty today that is
because of a violation occurred to the
Obama administration that's my way of
saying I don't know anything about
Siberian fires well but he's not a
Russian student he did in that call to
Vladimir Putin the reporters ask did you
raise anything about the election
meddling anyway to the reporter yeah
well you don't believe that do you just
of course after the Senate had very much
they talk a lot they talk a lot I was
gonna say what would be enough to say to
Putin about the election meddling other
than don't meddle in the election and
when he says that people would say well
that's not enough and then and then he
doesn't get the bill and he doesn't even
tell McConnell passed the election
that's right even bill I mean okay
anyway we did that yeah
sorry I think I think Putin says to him
things like you know well kill some of
our soldiers in Syria alright Josh isn't
the Fed cutting rates now just going to
make the next economic downturn worse
what's your prediction I've been hoping
for a recession people hate me for it
but yeah it would get rid of Trump so
you shouldn't hate me for it I mean
recessions are really bad people lose
their jobs and I know
and we shouldn't what it's worth it but
I don't I mean a recession is always
possible I don't see any particular
reason to think that it's likely I think
you know aren't we overdue for one just
know this like the cycle of economic
this is such a misconception people sort
of feel like oh you know well about
every eight years or something you're
supposed to have it recessions don't
come because they're due recessions come
because there's some sort of overheating
something goes wrong in the economy like
with the tech bubble in in 2000 and like
with the housing bubble and oh seven oh
eight the economy gets frothy and people
invest in things that don't turn out to
be useful and then everyone figures out
but you know there's all these tract
homes way out and you know in the high
desert that people don't want to buy and
then you have the crash and it has a
domino effect you get a recession
there's nothing that I look at in the
economy right now it looks like that's
about to happen now there are good signs
that the economy is slowing down that we
had faster growth in 2018 then we'll
have in 2019 some of that was there was
a little temporary effect from the tax
cut and so data is is a political
problem for the president the economy
won't be as good going into the election
next year probably as it has been this
year or last year but I think more
likely than not it will still be growing
just not as fast well that's gonna make
it tough recession how does Trump losers
I mean I think that that's what I wish
that Trump Lou there you go that's all I
was saying cuz all this stuff about
people saying right now the economy is
really bad Democrats have been trying to
make right doesn't fly guys I disagree
with you 43% first time I'm in 43 it's
true 43% of Michiganders just for
example can't even afford the basic
expenses we have this two-tiered economy
where you've got low unemployment
because people are working two and three
jobs and and if you don't have retire if
you don't have them but it's basically
votes that's if everyone who was in the
in that category yes vote voted but you
know people like that first of all
they're Senate
second of all they work they work they
can't get to the voting place sometimes
they're more likely to be shut out
because of Republican cheating yes they
do cheat with elections and make it
difficult right so you know I agree I
look at those figures I how could this
country be in them where you see these
polls or so many people think the
economy is great when like something
like you said 42 percent of people are
making minimum wage or less so much and
they don't have a money for an emergency
if it happens a week out or $100 they
don't even have four adela what they
don't they got a vote and they don't
it's a shame you can't school people
into voting everything that that
Jennifer was saying is true not just in
Michigan but across the board and I
think that many people who have not
voted that you've just described have
voted however dysfunctional II as an act
of rebellion because they do not believe
that they are being offered an
alternative to what is happening now
they feel the system is so deeply rigged
and that's why we have to create through
a much more truthful conversation about
how corrupt it is a sense among people
that there is a reason to try one more
time that there is a reason to vote
because this time we'll be doing
something nice but Marianne yes please
we like no we actually you didn't
interview a little while ago your
willingness to speak positively I think
is one of the main things that separated
you from those other Democrats on that
stage and I think that that really
resonated including with a lot of
conservatives that I know I'm not going
to name them someone get anybody in
trouble but just someone who took a
perspective of vision instead of just
everything is terrible things are going
to hell in a handbag did stats don't
prove that out a lot of weapon she did
say dark psychic yeah there's that but
no but you know Bhama one because yeah
he said there were problems we also said
there was inspiration I think a lot of
thank you
Hillary's very nearly one despite all of
her fairly unique problems as a can
Hillary she did win the popular vote she
wouldn't yes
I know but like it's so boring to like
always be like yeah cheer for our thing
that didn't doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it waste of everyone's time yes
you a little bit for president to win
three million more votes I speak for a
lot of American women who say it sure
does matter okay
are you satisfied with the format of the
Democratic debates I'm not I think it's
ridiculous I said that's the last debate
after that one that this is not a
serious country the way we do debates is
not serious you must have hated that
format I mean it's a huge you did well
but I mean it's a Thunderdome because
they let how we watch well first I
wouldn't give it to the [ __ ] networks
why should they be doing it they only
care about profit women voters did it
first of all no audience because you get
this same [ __ ] the audience is there
for the anchors right anchors are there
and they set everything up is like hey
this guy just said that shitty thing
about you what do you say about that
they're trying to get a fight gonna be
given to the network's maybe they're
gonna be done I mean there's a bunch of
them to come actually that's not really
the candidates fault it's the way the
moderator has made the question saying
and you're right it's not just about the
network about the political parties and
the fact that it used to be as you said
the League of Women Voters it's also
much theater it's so much dog and pony
show as opposed to the serious
conversations about our democracy that
needs to be high I mean I think first of
all you're never gonna have a satisfying
format with 20 candidates people were
saying you know well it's it's too long
and the answers were too short they
didn't talk about enough topics and so
like all three of those you can't fix
all three of those things but I think
you know that the moderating a debate is
about finding differences among the
candidates yeah so people say or they
wanted them to find cory booker they
should they should fight they should
make clear their ways in which they are
different from each other my hope was
that every candidate would be their best
and then let the voters see every
candidate be their best and then the
voters can decide for themselves through
their own intelligent and outlook what
you looking at this from the country
you're running president
[Applause]
thank you very much
you